[MUSIC]
The world of the chief financial
officer has changed dramatically.
It used to be about technical expertise,
being a great accountant.
Now CEOs need to make strategic
financial decisions and
in a changing dynamic environment.
They need to know how to become
truly effective leaders.
[MUSIC]
>> I needed of course that could
help me to become a better CFO.
>> The ability to become more engaged in
financial matters with our company was
an opportunity for advancement.
>> We expose the participants to experts
at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business.
Who have done research in the area of
leadership, as well as strategic thinking.
The participants, by engaging with these
experts as well as amongst themselves.
Will be able to learn these
attributes in a way that
helps accelerate their
path to becoming the CFO.
>> I've moved from the technical aspects
of being a finance professional,
to a strategic partner.
And I was looking for a class that
would help me jump to the next level.
>> This program brings finance leaders up
to date with what's happening right now.
And how to make financial
decisions much more effectively.
We want the participants to gain a greater
understanding of current trends in finance
and technology.
Develop a long-term vision and
appreciate strategy frameworks.
Assess and
enhance their personal leadership style to
be change-agents that drive innovation.
And lead to cultural change
in their organizations.
Here at Stanford they give you the best
of the best of what is happening in
the world of finance and strategy.
>> I'm going to take back a different
attitude, a different perspective.
>> It's not only the professor's,
the lectures, the cases, but
also the whole environment.
>> The ECFO program has been
a fantastic opportunity for me.
[MUSIC]
This program is supporting me
in every way, not only me,
it will support my organization.
[MUSIC]
>> It has been
a transformational experience.
[MUSIC]